Remember that a membership had joined Pakman,
Dotcom is the best way to help us as a country.
Get a fresh start here and you can indeed
use the coupon code fresh start all one word,
all lowercase, to save an ungodly amount of
money off of a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom.
Well, as votes continued and continue to be
counted, Donald Trump decided to hold a press
briefing yesterday.
He took no questions.
He was late.
His advisers were reportedly telling him,
don't do this, don't do this, because quite
frankly, how could it possibly go well for
him, given that he had been retweeting and
tweeting for two days about fraud, it is difficult
to imagine he could behave normally even for
the shortest of press briefings.
But he did it and it was a complete and total
humiliation.
Let's look at it.
We may be getting to the end of these for
Donald Trump, and that would be a beautiful
thing.
Donald Trump opening with a whopper saying
if you count the legal vote, I easily win.
But if you count the illegal votes, they might
be able to steal it if you count the legal
votes and easily win, if you count the illegal
votes, they can try to steal the election
from us if you count the votes that came in
late.
We're looking at them very strongly, but a
lot of votes came in late.
I've already decisively won many critical
states, including massive victories in Florida,
Iowa, Indiana, Ohio, to name just a few.
We won these and many other victories despite
historic election interference from big media,
big money and big tech.
This was a lie.
There is no evidence of election fraud other
than from his side trying to purge voter rolls
and have mail in ballots thrown out and have
a vote count stopped.
The only interference we've actually seen
is from his side.
Joe Biden throughout saying could take a little
while.
Let's give him time.
Let's remain calm.
Trump then says that polling was election
interference.
This is now Alex Jones type conspiracy nonsense.
Polling is election interference.
Take a look.
As everyone now recognizes, media polling
was election interference in the truest sense
of that word by powerful special interests.
These really phony polls, I have to call them
phony polls.
Fake polls were designed to keep our voters
at home, create the illusion of momentum for
Mr Biden and diminish Republicans ability
to raise funds.
They were what's called suppression polls.
Everyone knows that now.
And it's never been used to the extent that
it's been used in this last election.
To highlight just a few examples, the day
before the election, Quinnipiac, which was
wrong on every occasion that I know of that
I have to tell you, that's the first time
in this entire race I've heard Donald Trump
refer to Joe Biden as Mr Biden Sleepy Joe,
a phrase notably absent from this ill advised
press briefing.
Interesting to see that.
But also the content of what Donald Trump
is saying is ridiculous.
I also just as a little flavor, I love him
saying Quinnipiac.
They're just, you know, a little a little
extra.
You always have to add a little a little more
if you're Trump Trump then saying the entire
election system is corrupt, undermining confidence
at the top level, mind you, in the U.S., his
ability to carry out an election.
And of course, there are concerns, serious
concerns about election problems in this country,
but they are concerns as a result of the things
Trump side does, not the ones Trump is pointing
out.
And we want a case, a big case, and we have
others happening.
There are a lot of lots of litigation even
beyond our litigation.
There's tremendous amount of litigation generally
because of how unfair this process was.
And I predicted that I've been talking about
mail and voting for a long time.
It's it's really destroyed our system.
It's a corrupt system and it makes people
corrupt, even if they aren't by nature, but
they become corrupt.
It's too easy.
He's right.
I mean, you you know, you've got to hand it
to him.
He did predict that he would do this.
We knew he would do it, and he's doing every
aspect of it.
On Monday, I told you Trump will claim victory
on election night, even though there won't
be such a victory, at least at that time.
And he did it at two a.m., two thirty in the
morning.
I told you Trump would claim that there was
fraud and he immediately started doing it.
I told you Trump would try to get courts to
get involved, to hand him a victory.
And he has filed somewhere between four and
seven, eight.
I don't even know the number of lawsuits at
this point.
So he told us he would do it.
And I passed that information along to you.
And he did it exactly as we predicted.
Then, as if this isn't crazy enough, then
it gets really insane.
After arguing that Michigan, Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin were rigged against him because
all the votes were counted, Trump calls for
all the votes to be counted in Arizona.
He's blatantly trying to have it both ways.
The counting of votes was a problem in a bunch
of these states, but Arizona just should keep
counting and then I'll win.
And now it's getting to be to a point where
I'll go from winning by a lot to perhaps being
even down a little bit.
In Georgia, pipe burst and a far away location
totally unrelated to the location of what
was happening.
And they stopped counting for four hours and
a lot of things happened.
The election apparatus in Georgia is run by
Democrats.
We.
Also had margins of 300000 and Michigan way
up and Michigan won the state and in Wisconsin
we did likewise fantastically well and that
got whittled down in every case they got whittled.
Today, we're on track to win Arizona.
We only need to carry, I guess, 55 percent
of the remaining vote, 55 percent.
So really understand that he casually says
all this counting is rigged against me in
all of these states that I lost due to mail
in ballots.
But, you know, in Arizona, you've just got
to things look great in Arizona.
As long as they keep counting ballots, then
I'll probably win.
This is not democracy as we know it.
This is a joke.
This is a mockery.
Even I don't want to use any any kind of pejorative
term, but even in the most authoritarian.
What I don't want to say undeveloped countries,
but even in countries where we have all along
been questioning their ability to maintain
democracy, you often don't get things as ridiculous
as this from the leaders.
Trump is outdoing even them.
And then Trump actually says that he's using
tremendous litigation to stop people from
rigging the election.
And there are many instances which will be
reported very shortly.
There's tremendous litigation going on.
And this is a case where they're trying to
steal an election, they're trying to rig an
election, and we can't let that happen.
Detroit and Philadelphia, known as two of
the most corrupt political places anywhere
in our country, easily cannot be responsible
for engineering the outcome of a presidential
race, a very important presidential race in
Pennsylvania.
Democrats have gone to the state Supreme Court
to try and ban our election observers.
And very strongly now we won the case.
But they're there going forward.
They don't want anybody in there.
They don't want anybody watching them as they
count the ballots.
There is no evidence for anything that Donald
Trump is saying.
And when he posted some of these clips I'm
playing for you to his Twitter account, Twitter
flagged them as potential misinformation about
elections.
Trump then alludes to pushing his bogus legal
challenges all the way to the Supreme Court,
will have the name Biden on him, which is
a little strange.
I challenge Joe and every Democrat to clarify
that they only want legal votes because they
talk about votes.
And I think they should use the word illegal
legal votes.
We want every legal vote counted and I want
every legal vote counted.
We want openness and transparency.
No secret count rooms, no mystery ballots,
no illegal votes being cast after Election
Day.
You have Election Day and the laws are very
strong and that you have an election day and
they don't want votes cast after Election
Day and they want the process to be an honest
one.
It's so important.
We want an honest election and we want an
honest count and we want honest people working
back there because it's a very important job.
So that's the way this country is going to
win.
That's the way the United States will win.
And we think we will win the election very
easily.
We think there's going to be a lot of litigation
because we have so much evidence, so much
proof, and it's going to end up perhaps at
the highest court in the land.
We'll see.
But we think there'll be a lot of litigation
because we can't have an election stolen like
this.
And so the message is Trump is such a victim,
everybody's unfair.
Everybody's being mean.
They won't just let them win and give him
another four years.
He needs counts when the counts help.
And he needs to stop counting when the counting
is bad and he'll sue everyone and he'll never
concede defeat, even if that's what needs
to happen.
And then Trump casually mentions on the way
out without taking questions, of course, that
he has claimed states, states that have not
actually been called for him.
So it will be hopefully cleared up maybe soon.
I hope soon, but it'll probably go through
a process, a legal process.
And as you know, I've claimed certain states
and he's claiming states so we can both claim
the states.
But ultimately, I have a feeling judges are
going to have to rule.
But there's been a lot of shenanigans and
we can't stand for that in our country.
Thank you very much.
Are you being absorbed to understand that
Trump casually says, I've claimed states and
Biden has claimed states, Biden has claimed
no states.
Biden is accepting the calls of the Associated
Press and state election commissions and networks
and election officials.
That's what Biden has done.
Trump is the one claiming states like Georgia,
Pennsylvania and North Carolina, which at
the time he was doing it, had not been called.
Biden is accepting the calls of others and
saying count every vote, regardless of what
state it's in, whether it came in by mail
or in person.
Trump is claiming states that have not been
called so seriously.
Guys, this is hopefully the last gasp of Trump.
Anderson Cooper likened it to a turtle on
its back.
Take a look at this most powerful person in
the world.
And we see him like an obese turtle on his
back, flailing in the hot sun, realizing his
time is over.
But he just hasn't accepted it and he wants
to take everybody down with him so there will
be legal challenges, there is the real possibility
that Trump will find a way to continue extending
this and even rumor that Fox News will refuse
to refer to Joe Biden as president elect regardless
of the outcome, on the basis that his status
would be challenged.
We'll have more of that, but so much more
to get to